hello Cascadia welcome to the N API
session my name is Etta Shea and I'm a
developer at Adobe I'm here today to get
you all excited about writing native
modules in no js' in building
functionality that would bridge the
grand old C++ language with the modern
the hip the class II JavaScript a few
tidbits about me I work in San Francisco
and I am co-located with most of the
former flash team here's a view of this
San Francisco skyline right from my desk
over the years I've worked with a
variety of technology stacks I've worked
on flagship desktop applications
award-winning mobile software but my
heart still lies with the vamp the first
website that I worked on was all in
flash and the lamp stack we cared a lot
about ie6 back then over time I have
moved on and covered up the HTML
progression with that I've been
rewriting my website
the latest rewrite happened just a month
ago when I moved off bootstrap on to CSS
grid and Adobe I work on a background
process this process synchronizes all
the network i/o that adobe applications
due to the cloud
since it is i/o heavy the best
technology to write this in is no js'
and adobe this ship a node.js based
process a node.js based background
process to millions of customers that
run our products if you've used
Photoshop in the last three four years
you would have interacted with this
process in the background since we
shipped to a variety of machine
configurations and node.js is really
built for the server side there are some
issues that node doesn't solve and for
that we need to go down to the native
layer and to go down to the native layer
means working in C++ I am the go-to guy
in my team to
with C++ and I've been doing it for the
last three years in this talk today
we'll talk about why we should write or
when we should write native code we will
talk about the various ways to interact
with native code from Vidin nodejs we
will go through a running example of a n
a n n API based plugin to node.js a
module that looks like JavaScript but is
written in C++ we will do a synchronous
asynchronous version as well and then
we'll be also running it in electron
I'll share some tips and tricks to be
successful in the native world and leave
you all with a bunch of resources to
play with at the end of the conference
as JavaScript developers we are like
astronauts we fly in the space and don't
really care about what happens down at
the mother earth actually sometimes we
do have to sometimes each Iowa script
developers do have to go down a layer
into the world of unmanaged memory of
multi-threaded architectures and my
favorite segmentation faults this what
let me talk about what this talk is not
about this talk is not about the v8
engine the engine that's used to build
node.js we will not be going into the v8
internals or learning how it works
this talk is also not about the C++
programming language why we will be
using C++ there are better ways to learn
C++ this talk is also not about
improving the performance of your node
based application frankly speaking
poorly written native code would be a
lot worse than average JavaScript code
it would crash your app what this talk
is really about is about building
modules it's about extending the node
ecosystem with the functionality that
was not practically or efficiently
possible with the current state of
JavaScript it's about writing a module
that looks and behaves just like any
other module in the node
ecosystem but in from the insight is
written in a very different way so let's
get started why would we write native
code that's a big question that comes up
whenever we talk about native code
javascript has everything well there are
a few things that make JavaScript
slightly difficult to write for example
your OSS are mostly written in C C++ or
expose their functionality in those
languages something new came out the
dark mode in Mohave what do you do do
you wait for it to be standardized to
use it in a node app you could directly
include it for in C++ in electron you
could write C++ code to read the current
state or the dark mode and show it to
the user
the second big reason to write native
code is if you have some C++ code lying
around C++ is a thirty-year-old
developed very values language we have
tons of production ready code in C++ and
not all of that compiles to webassembly
so kind we are kind of forced if you
want to do you want to rewrite
everything in jeaious or maybe just for
this case let's use what we have and
that is a very good use case for going
down native another important case where
we actually have to go down native is
when we need to crunch numbers now
javascript is the best language for
doing i/o if you have to communicate
over the network or file system is your
main mode of communication right yes
don't go native but then if you have to
do heavy number crunching something that
would burn the CPU hot it's better to go
down to the native layer you'll save
quite a lot of dollars in summary the
only reason to write native code is that
we are not JavaScript developers we are
solution providers to a problem and we
are building race cars
we love the metal too much but then in a
race car we do need some plastic we do
need some rubber and therefore to build
a race car let's assemble everything so
let's talk about the various ways to
communicate with native code in node.js
process that's my favorite and I think
that's the one that most of you would
have already used child process comes
natively in node you can just require
child process from any of your modules
and huge trial process child process
runs in its own process and therefore
you can write typical Nord code your no
thread would not be blocked when a child
process is running you can get it to run
asynchronously pass it arguments and
take that as a result a process it's
perfect perfect for what it does but it
does have a few limitations and there
are a few cases where it does not work
that well what if the functionality that
you want is not natively available or
easily possible with a shell script or a
bad script or direct command line are
you willing to ship another binary will
that binary work well given the
antivirus that some user has installed
somewhere in Japan how do I know and
that is a big reason to be careful with
child processes you're writing into
shell directly and there are cases where
it's not a good idea especially if stdio
is not enough the communication with
child processes normally happens to the
standard input output and error ports
now the problem with that is it's good
if you want to work with that but say
you're passing a large amount of image
data you'll have to go down to the file
system which is very complicated child
process is like a tow-truck it can get
you to your destination but I would
never want to talk about that let's talk
about something better FFI or foreign
function injection FFI is not really a
node concept it is a concept that's
there in all programming languages the
binary interface of the C programming
languages has been standardized as the
interface for information exchange
between languages in short if you have a
C style library then any language can
read through the binary and directly
call into the functionality so if a
method is exporting a C style library
you can directly read it from nodejs and
call into it
no writing C++ no writing C you are
still in GS and there is a native module
available in node called f fi or f fi
napi in node 10-plus which can do that
it is actually the best approach if you
have a library with C style code lying
there
the reason you can use it in multiple
languages your C guy can write the C
code and you can focus on Jas but it has
its own set of disadvantages for example
the J's bridge to C++ is still slow the
other big disadvantage which affects GS
developers is that C developers like to
take on the main thread if the C library
is actually slow and you're actually
doing number crunching you would want to
do this in a background thread don't
stall my application while this thing is
running and you cannot do that with FF I
for doing something like that you need
more something more advanced FF I is
more like a toy it works for what it
works but if it doesn't look for a
better solution now note is build in v8
v8 is a C++ based library and what that
means is you can directly call C++ why
are the v8 API is excellent and extend
node so simple you'll get the full
performance of v8 you can extend v8 and
write new JavaScript maybe write es 2019
in your module but then there is one big
problem
v8 releases a new version every month
and they cannot guarantee the
compatibility of their API across
releases what that means is that if I
write a node module using the v8 API is
next month I'm I need to rewrite it no
one can maintain that and that node team
realized it very early that is why they
created na N and wrapper over the v8 API
which hides the changes as v8 changes
and if you use any and you can recompile
your module across various versions of
node and it will continue to run nor
rewriting needed NN was built as a
specific solution to a very specific
problem that was to hide v8 and it does
the job perfectly but it was never
thought out to be a very well-defined
C++ interface
jiae's communication and it starts to
show its age for example you need to
understand v8 to use any and properly
you need to recompile with every release
people who use multiple versions of
north would have seen this error at some
point or the other this error comes in
because of any n n n is highly tied to a
version of node and so if you want to
switch your node version there are
problems more than that if you happen to
be writing electron and have your unit
tests in node you will only be
recompiling for the entire day another
issue with any n is that it's so
complicated to set up any n that you
will be actually ending up setting up
your production machine to have a C
compiler a Python compiler and the
JavaScript runtime just to use
JavaScript in production which is not
really a good thing to do any n is like
manual transmission you need to know
what gear to go into for your
application to work otherwise this error
awaits now if any n is manual let's talk
about the automatic the n API the N API
has been marked stable with no ten and
for the last 15 days no 10 has been the
LTS version of node so n API is
production-ready n api has a very
well-defined binary interface that is it
is a bi-stable in short the node team
guarantees that if you write something
using the N API you can not only use it
in the past versions of node node eight
where it was experimental and no 10 but
also in the future versions the node a
node team will gain will try to make
sure that your napi mod you stays
relevant and you do not need to
recompile across your users n api
provides a full set of utility methods
to communicate with c++ in a proper JS
way for example it hides all the
complications around pointers it hides
how to create a background thread in a
very simple method and electron rebuild
is officially dead once we have all
plugins that have moved to the N API
now before I talk about how to write
some napi code I would like to know how
many if you've heard about C++ before my
talk everyone how many of you actually
used C++ or written C++ code it's quite
a few how many of you will love C++ love
it more than JavaScript again at your
question because C++ is much more
difficult to write and unless you really
need to I would prefer to stay in the
jail and less socials to show some
sample an API based code so I have a es6
module that exports a property X which
is a function that returns hello world
this is what it would look like in es5
slightly more verbose but look at C++ it
looks very complicated but actually it's
very simple from the C++ standards at
the bottom of the file we have this node
API module which is declaring that the
module dot exports come from the export
method and the name of the module comes
from the JIP file the JIP file is
equivalent to packet or JSON in the
native world in the exports method we
are setting a property X to be the Foo
function which has been converted from a
c function to a JS function and in the
Foo function we are returning a string
hello world at the top of the file there
is any P I dot H which we are including
include is kind of like imports I think
most of us are C++ developers so I don't
need to go into details for all of that
now what we'll be doing today is
building or showing a running native
module let's go to a hypothetical
situation that I have been very lucky in
Vegas
and not only that all of you have been
luckier so while I get some cash you get
to drive a brand new car and as you
drive through the Vegas Strip you see me
in your sideview mirror and for another
lucky break it's actually raining in
Vegas and that is what we would be doing
we'll be taking an image adding a rain
effect to it overlaying it with another
image and fitting it inside a frame we
are doing all of this using imagemagick
image magic is an open source C++ API
for image manipulation very popular on
the server side very popular on the
command line you can read all about it
it's all over the Internet
so let's get started and I'm here in the
middle of a test file where I'm loading
a module called version dot node in
version dot node we export a method
called version which returns the current
node version as a string and I'm logging
it onto the console let's look at
binding dot chip which represents the
packet or JSON for this module it has
the similar things just like packet or
JSON the name is called target name
because we are C++ developers you want
to make it a bit more confusing than it
has dependencies which is an array and
it can run some shell scripts or note
scripts directly we have some flags to
tell the compiler how to compile it and
we have some OS specific stuff and that
is all there is to it when node would
read this file it would understand that
it is native code and compile this
binary let's go into the binary version
or the C++ version of this module this
looks exactly like the demo that a
sample code that I just showed so at the
bottom of the file we again have known
API module the name comes from the JIP
file there is a method called init which
has a property called version which is
the function get version in the get
version function we are returning a
string which we are instead of
hard-coding hello world getting from the
imagemagick api which we've included by
a magic plus plus dot h now as i execute
this and my
a console I think it's slightly
difficult to see we have image magic
version 7 being logged that is the
version of image magic that's installed
on my machine now that we've gone
through a hello world I will like you to
go through something a little more
complicated so in this second example we
are reading a file called photos or JPEG
which is a binary image file please
don't point at read file sync I know
it's bad code once we get the image file
we load the info dot node info provider
native module which exports a method
process image which is going to process
this image and return a.j saab jekt this
object I am logging on to console many
JavaScript developers don't know that
JSON dot stringify actually can take
more than one argument the third
argument of JSON dot stringify is
extremely useful this is the number of
white spaces so you can get a pretty
fide JSON string from a JavaScript
object directly without going to J's
beautify or whatever you guys are using
coming back to native code let's look at
info dot CC the code for the info dot
node module the bottom of the file looks
exactly like I've just shown to you all
of you the name comes from the JIP file
the init method provides the exports the
expose is actually a property called
process image which comes from the
process image C++ function now let's get
into the process image function the
first thing to note is that it doesn't
take multiple arguments it takes an info
object this info object is very similar
to the arguments object in Jas or the
triple dot args like you write in es6
then from this info object we can verify
that the parameters being passed are
correct and if they are not we throw a
JS exception why we want to do that
they're still living in the world of
segmentation false if we make a mistake
our program would crash and therefore we
want to be extra careful it's better to
get into the unhandled exception in the
notes place rather than crashing here in
C once we know that it is a buffer we
can convert it from a raw JSON buffer
typescript folks would understand that
this looks very close to typescript
and generic since
plus plus have been an inspiration for a
lot of languages including typescript
once we converted to a buffer we have
direct access to the raw binary data and
the length of the buffer we can use this
to pass on and create an image magic
image now from the image I'm not doing
much I'm reading the width and the
height of the image a few attributes and
then creating a JS object creating a J's
in C++ is a little more verbose than
creating it is in GS so I need to create
an object with the width height created
and modified parameters which I again
get from the number in string tied data
and then I return it back to node now as
I executed in my debug console you
should see that I'm loading a full at
the image the mod if the Creator time is
actually right now and that is because I
passed on a binary image to image magic
image magic did not get to read a file
from disk and that is why it was just
created when the binary editor was
provided and it did not have a modified
time the demo that I just showed was
kind of a example that we would not like
to use in production it's doing
processing in the main thread right and
main thread stalls and our application
stops working so let's do something
where it goes to a background thread
takes a callback gives us the processed
image in our callback now we pass it on
and save the file as edit dot JPEG on to
our console let's look at the code for
edit dot C C now this also starts just
like the code that I showed for the
previous two examples we again get the
name from the Gipp file the init method
provides a method called edit which is
the function edit in the function edit
we validate the arguments just like we
did in the previous example and then
instead of doing some calculation we
create a worker called image modifier
which takes the buffer and they call
back and then we queue that worker on a
background thread we are not creating
background threads manually oh god it's
so difficult to create background
threads things like deadlocks they stall
your application
do not waste CPU but you don't run this
is so much better
and API provides direct access to run
stuff in a background thread and it
manages the thread pool now let's look
at the image modifier class event
modifier derived from an async worker
which and capsule eights all the
background thread calculations a sync
worker takes a callback and it ensures
the unmanaged memory part of C++ so when
we need the koala back back again after
execution in the background thread the
async worker will ensure that the
callback has not been garbage collected
by v8 and we can use it again we can
directly copy in values that we get like
numbers and strings but in this case I
am passing a lot of binary data and we
don't want to copy the binary data in
the J's thread and that is why we are
using the node buffer despite the
presence of array buffers nor buffer is
not dead because of a reason node buffer
is a very special object the binary data
of node buffer is accessible even from
background threads and that is why node
buffer still exists and to do that what
we are doing is you're marking it
persistent so that accidentally the node
buffer does not get deleted it will get
garbage collected once this class object
is destroyed and then we are keeping a
reference to the actual binary data and
the length of the data to pass on to
image magic and API will ensure that my
execute method is actually called in the
background thread now in the execute
method I am passing on that image data
to image magic I'm loading a few images
I specified array in effect I overlay it
with my water image and then change its
dimension to fit it inside the car frame
once I am done I can write this output
to another variable we don't have to
write to disk now note is happy passing
this variable directly to the J's land
we do not need to copy it over or waste
our memory or CPU doing things with the
data we can directly use it in Jas but
unfortunately event magic does not allow
me to and therefore I need to copy this
data into a binary object into a basic
object now to do that
I'm using this but this is not really
stalling your JavaScript read all this
code is running in your background
thread in the execute method so your JS
code will still be performant once that
method executes we get to the on ok
method which is again called in the J's
thread where we can execute JavaScript
and this method what we are doing is
getting a callback and calling it with
undefined as the error argument and D
buffer as the success argument now
there's one more thing that we need to
remember and that is this line which is
not really declaring a c++ variable that
we are not going to use this is actually
creating a J scope all functions in J s
are automatically having a scope but
since we are not creating a function we
directly calling a function we need to
create a scope manually and once the
scope is destroyed if any of the objects
created in the scope are not referenced
anywhere
there could be garbage collected now
let's see how I create the buffer to
pass on the buffer is again created by
the buffer new just like you were using
string new or a number new a buffer is
slightly more complicated in sense that
it takes this an asynchronous function
called a C++ lambda we need to do this
because C++ still has managed doesn't
have managed memory so for unmanaged
memory when this buffer is actually
garbage collected we will need to free
the internal data and that is what we
are doing now as I execute this you
won't see anything in the console but
will successfully log done and instead
of showing what I was doing since I'm
running out of time I'll show you
something cooler now what I'm going to
do is without recompiling I'm going to
load it in electron and as I click on
this here it is the same code running an
electron no recompilation and i am going
to make a fool of myself now as i take a
selfie of myself in front of all of you
on the stage yeah
and it does that processing and it's
instantly available for me to save now
the same thing is available at napi dot
efficient dot me feel free to try it out
after my speech and have a souvenir for
the conference and I'm already out of
time so I'll just make it quick
the best tips to work with native code
are actually three things rule number
one do not write native code try to see
if something that is not native can
solve the problem for you because child
processes are good for a lot of cases
and so is FFI and unless you really need
native code do not write native code the
second rule of writing native code is do
not give it to a native developer
because they don't understand Jas
they'll hog your main thread write it
like beautiful Jas and ugly C++ and you
will be successful the third rule of
writing native code is again to remember
the first rule don't write native god if
you have it in some native code just
evaluate if you need it Jas is evolving
and over time more and more stuff is
moving to Jas what you needed in native
a year back may be redundant now keep
yourself up to date the code for all of
my demos are available at napi in my
github repo the sample service is
available at n API dot Atisha dot me
that's all I have to say drive safely
if you're going to use native code thank
you